FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
NOW, LIBERALS TODAY THINK THAT
AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY WHITE
AMERICANS, ARE PRETTY MUCH THE
WORST THING OUT THERE.
IN OTHER WORDS, ANYONE WHO
DOESN'T SIGN ONTO THE VIEW THAT
AMERICA IS FUNDAMENTALLY RACIST
AND EVIL, EXPECT THEM TO BE
CALLED A WHITE SUPREMACIST AND
PUBLICLY VILIFIED.
FOR EXAMPLE, ACCORDING TO A NEW
BOOK, BIDEN ASSESSED FOX NEWS AS
ONE OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FORCES IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND REPORTERS JONATHAN MARTIN
AND ALEXANDER BURNS WRITE THAT
BIDEN WAS EVEN MORE CRITICAL OF
FOX CORPS PATRIOT ROBERT MURDOCH
SAYING MURDOCH "WAS THE MOST
DANGEROUS MAN IN THE WORLD."
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANS.
MORE DANGEROUS THAN PUTIN, MORE
DANGEROUS THAN XI, MORE
DANGEROUS THAN KIM JONG UN.
OK.
AND AS THE "ANGLE" HAS TOLD YOU
MANY TIMES, TODAY'S DEMOCRAT
PARTY BELIEVES CONSERVATIVES ARE
A FAR BIGGER THREAT TO AMERICA
THAN THE BIGGEST DICTATORS IN
THE WORLD.
WE WARNED YOU ABOUT THIS.
REMEMBER, MORE EVIL THAN THE
DICTATORS THAT HAVE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS POINTED AT THE UNITED
STATES, AND, WELL, WE WERE
RIGHT.
NOW, BUT SOME PEOPLE REQUIRE
MORE DIRECT PROOF.
NOW, LET'S TAKE THE CASE OF
ANDREW SULLIVAN, THE SUPREMELY
TALENTED WRITER AND WELL-KNOWN
COMMENTATOR WHO WROTE THE
SEMINOLE BOOK FOR GAY MARRIAGE
AND IS EXTREMELY ANTI-TRUMP.
PERHAPS HE THOUGHT THAT HIS
WITHERING CRITICISM OF TRUMP
WOULD HAVE EARNED HIM FAIR
TREATMENT AS A GUEST ON A SHOW
HOSTED BY THE EVER-SNARKY JON
STEWART.
BUT HE WAS WRONG.
INSTEAD, FORMERLY INSISTING THAT
THE STORY OF AMERICA IS NOT ONE
OF IRREDEEMABLE EVIL, HE WAS
ANNIHILATED.
HERE'S HOW IT ALL STARTED.
JON STEWART PAYING HOMAGE TO THE
RACE GODS OF THE BLM MOVEMENT.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH WHITE
PEOPLE.
FOR HOWEVER SINCERELY WE WANT TO
RECKON AND LISTEN, THE TRUTH IS
AMERICA HAS ALWAYS PRIORITIZED
WHITE COMFORT OVER BLACK
SURVIVAL.
BLACK PEOPLE HAVE HAD TO FIGHT
SO HARD FOR EQUALITY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN IRREPAIRABLE SET
BACK IN THE PURSUIT OF EQUITY --
EITHER REP ABLY SET BACK IN THE
PURSUIT OF EQUITY.
ANY ATTEMPT TO REPAIR A TON OF
THAT DAMAGE, REPARATION.
IT SETS OFF WHITE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE COMING FOR OUR [BLEEP]
LAW.
>> THE PANELIST WENT ALONG AND
THEY THEMSELVES HIT THE BUTTONS
SAYING WHITE SUPREMACY IS ALIVE
AND WELL IN THE UNITED STATES.
ANDREW SULLIVAN HIT BACK AND
DEFENDED AMERICA.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO AGREE WITH
SOME OF THE VERY PREMISES THAT
ARE BEING EXPRESSED TONIGHT.
AS IF EVERYTHING IS ALREADY
SETTLED, WE KNOW THIS COUNTRY S
FOR EXAMPLE, A WHITE SUPREMACY
-- IS, FOR EXAMPLE A WHITE
SUPREMACY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLY THE MOST
ABSURD HYPERBOLE.
I COME FROM -- I'M AN IMMIGRANT.
I HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VIEW
OF THIS.
I CAN TELL YOU AMERICA IN 2022
IS THE MOST MULTI-RACIAL,
MULTI-CULTURAL, TOLERANT,
DIVERSE MELTING POT THAT'S EVER
EXISTED ON PLANET EARTH AND
THERE'S NO OTHER PLACE ON EARTH
EVEN LIKE IT.
THAT'S WHY 86% OF OUR IMMIGRANTS
ARE NONWHITE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION,
ANDREW.
>> Laura: ALL REASONABLE
POINTS, ALL WELL-EXPRESSED BUT
NOT TO THE OTHER PANELIST A
WOMAN NAMED LISA BOND WHO MAKES
A LIVING LECTURING OTHER WHITE
WOMEN WILL HOW RACEST THEY ARE
-- ABOUT HOW RACIST THEY ARE.
SHE WAS DEEPLY OFFENDED A WHITE
MAN WOULD ARGUE THAT THE U.S. IS
NOT SYSTEMATICALLY RACIST.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WHITE
PEOPLE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT, IS
YOU HAVE RACIST TROPES LIKE THIS
THAT PERPETUATE, PERPETUATE AND
PERPETUATE, SO I AM -- AND I DID
NOT COME ON THIS SHOW TO SIT
HERE AND ARGUE WITH ANOTHER
WHITE MAN.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WE
DON'T EVEN ENGAGE WITH WHITE MEN
AT OUR CENTER, BECAUSE QUITE
HONESTLY, IF WHITE MEN WERE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
RACISM, YOU HAD 400 YEARS.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE IT.
OK?
SO --
>> I'M 58 YEARS OLD.
>> I'M SHUTTING YOU DOWN RIGHT
NOW.
>> I'M NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYONE BEFORE ME.
>> Laura: HE SAID I'M NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANYONE BEFORE
ME.
THAT'S A TRIGGER WARNING.
>> WE HAVE AN AWFUL HISTORY.
IT'S -- ITS REMNANTS --
>> WE ALSO HAVE A GREAT HISTORY.
>> BUT I THINK YOU'RE MINIMIZING
IT, BECAUSE --
>> I THINK BY CALLING TODAY
WHITE SUPREMACY, YOU'RE
MINIMIZING ACTUAL WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> ANDREW, YOU'RE NOT LIVING ON
THE SAME [BLEEP] PLANET WE ARE.
HONESTLY.
I REALLY DON'T THINK YOU ARE.
>> I THINK YOU'RE NOT LIVING ON
THE PLANET MOST AMERICANS ARE
WHICH IS WHY THIS KIND OF
EXTREMISM, THIS ANTI-WHITE
SUPREMISM IS LOSING POPULAR
SUPPORT, IS CREATING A BACKLASH
AND WILL ELECT REPUBLICANS AND
UNDO A LOT OF THE GOOD YOU THINK
YOU'RE DOING.
>> Laura: HE MIGHT HAVE ASKED
STEWART, A GRADUATE OF WILLIAM &
MARY F STEWART BURNED HIS OLD
DIPLOMA AND SOCCER JERSEY
BECAUSE THE COLLEGE WAS BUILT IN
PART BY SLAVE LABOR AND SOME OF
ITS PRESIDENTS OWNED SLAVES.
>> I DON'T CARE IF WE SAY WE'RE
PROGRESSIVE.
I DON'T CARE IF WE'RE LITERALLY
MEMBERS OF THE KKK, EVERY SINGLE
WHITE PERSON UPHOLDS THE SYSTEMS
AND STRUCTURES OF WHITE
SUPREMACY AND WE HAVE GOT TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> IF I COULD FINGER SNAP, I
WOULD FINGER SNAP RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU'D BE FINGER SNAPPING BY
CALLING ME A RACIST, JON.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DOING A PRETTY
GOOD JOB WITH YOURSELF THERE SO
--
>> Laura: YEAH, SO THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE IN AMERICA.
THAT WOMAN HAS PASSED OFF AS
SOME TYPE OF EXPERT IN ANYTHING,
AND YOU'RE A WHITE SUPREMACIST
OR A RACIST IF YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH JON STEWART THAT IMMIGRANTS
SHOULDN'T BE BLAMED FOR SLAVERY.
THIS IS THE ONGOING SCAM OF THE
ANTI-RACISM MOVEMENT.
THEY GET PAID HANDSOME SUMS TO
TELL CORPORATE AND ACADEMIC
AUDIENCES HOW AWFUL TO THE CORE
THEY ALL ARE AND THEY NOW HAVE
THOUSANDS OF ACCOLADES ACROSS
COUNTRY WHO ARE ALSO EAGER TO
CASH IN AS WELL.
OR WHO LIKE STEWART JUST ENJOY
THE MORAL SUPERIORITY THEY FEEL
BY CALLING EVERYONE ELSE A
RACIST.
SO IF YOU REFUSE TO BUY INTO THE
ALLY SHIFT -- DON'T YOU LOVE
THAT WORD -- AND THE PRIVILEGE
LINGO, IF YOU REFUSE TO SAY YOU
SUPPORT REPARATIONS, YOU ARE AS
DESPICABLE AS ANY SLAVEHOLDER
FROM THE EARLY 1800'S THAT'S
WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
YOU THINK I'M EXAGGERATING?
POST OUT WHAT JON STEWART MOSTED
ON HIS TWITTER.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH WHITE PEOPLE
IS EVERYTHING.
>> THE WHOM WITH WHITE PEOPLE IS
THE MECHANISM THAT HAS POP UP TO
PROTECT PRIVILEGE ANYTIME RACE,
EQUITY OR RACIST SYSTEMS COME
UP.
>> I EAT, I NEVER OWNED SLAVES.
>> THE REAL PROBLEM WITH WHITE
PEOPLE IS HOW DEEPLY ENTRENCHED.
>> Laura: JON STEWART IS
BLISSLY UNAWARE.
HE NEEDED TO HAVE THE WHOLE
SITUATION BE LIKE A THREE
AGAINST ONE.
THEN HE TAGGED HIM AS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
AND HE'S THE SAME SNARING PRIG
WHO 18 YEARS AGO LECTURED THE
HOST OF CROSSFIRE ON CNN ABOUT
THE NEED FOR MORE RESPECTFUL,
MORE INFORMED DISCOURSE.
WELL TODAY, HE'S JUST ANOTHER
RACE ACTIVIST, DESPERATE FOR
CREDIBILITY IN AN AMERICA THAT
AS ANDREW SAID IS THE MOST
MULTI-CULTURAL, MULTI-ETHNIC
THAT IT'S EVER BEEN.
HE AND ALMOST THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRAT PARTY RADICALIZED BY
THE FRINGES RAIL AGAINST THE OLD
PERNICIOUS PRACTICE OF RED
LINING WHILE THEY ESSENTIALLY
HOPE TO RED LINE THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
AND INSTEAD OF TRYING TO WIN
OVER AMERICA FIRST POPULOUS OR
INDEPENDENTS LIKE SULLIVAN OR
SOMEONE LET'S SAY LIKE A GLEN
GREENWALL, THEY TRY TO DESTROY
THEM OR MAKE THEM SO TOXIC THAT
THEY CAN'T EVEN MAKE A LIVING IN
ANY MAINSTREAM SETTING.
AGAIN, THESE PEOPLE SEE NO
LOGICAL INCONSISTENCY IN THE
FACT THAT THE CCP IS STILL
ACTIVE ON TWITTER WHILE TRUMP,
MAYBE SOMEONE LIKE SULLIVAN IS
BANNED.
IN FACT, THEY'RE FINE WITH THAT.
THEY HAVE TO BAN TRUMP.
THEY HAVE TO INVESTIGATE HIM.
THEY HAVE TO HOPE TO PROSECUTE
HIM.
PUT HIM IN JAIL.
ANYTHING.
ANYTHING BUT DEBATE HIM.
AND TRY TO DEFEND THEIR
ABYSMALLY HORRIBLE RECORD
RUNNING OUR SCHOOLS, OUR CITIES
AN